[Applaudissements]
alors ce projet s'inscrit dans une
volonté de l'ensemble des douze communes
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de
dynamiser l'accueil des Jeux Olympiques
sur le territoire pour célébrer ce
moment pour qu'il soit bénéfice de toute
la population l'objectif c'est
d'impliquer notre population nous avons
souhaité le faire avec les 12 communes à
travers le tissu associatif de 50 ans en
Yvelines celui du monde sportif mais
également celui du monde culturel par
exemple bref toutes les associations du
territoire et des douze communes qui
voudront célébrer les jeux et les faire
en sorte que la population s'implique au
maximum pour l'accueil des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024
alors on va sur le site tout simplement
de 50 ans en Yvelines et on va sur le
portail des associations pourra retirer
son dossier on le remplit on dépose sa
candidature nous nous courons du mois de
novembre alors si on a jusqu'au 3
octobre pour remplir ce dossier courant
du mois de novembre nous réunissons un
comité dans lequel l'ensemble des
communes sont représentées les
spécialistes du monde associatif de 50
ans Yvelines également et nous
choisirons sur dossier les projets qui
nous sembleront les plus en adéquation
avec la queue des Jeux Olympiques et
surtout le fait de célébrer ces jeux à
travers notre plus belle action et au
bénéfice de notre population
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment tout au long de l'année
2024 bien évidemment avant les Jeux et
juste avant les Jeux mais depuis le 1er
janvier le but c'est vraiment de faire
en sorte que la population s'approprie
ces jeux et participe à ce moment de
festivités et ça peut être tout à fait
des activités diverses n'est pas
forcément des activités sportives bien
sûr ce seront des activités sportives
mais encore une fois ça peut être des
activités culturelles ce peut être
d'autres types d'activités qui vont
faire en sorte que chacun ressente le
moment magnifique que vont être les Jeux
Olympiques à 50 ans en Yvelines
[Applaudissements]